the war from the skies has become the
soundtrack of the unrelenting effort to
try to contain one of the biggest
wildfires in greece this week aircraft
unloading vast containers of water onto
the still burning earth below
and watching and waiting a residence of
the village engulfed by the fire forced
to flee very bobby and still being
prevented from returning
it was in my neighbor's behind
field which i saw the flames were
high i don't know how much
high it was it wasn't impossible i was i
started crying
i started crying
the fire raced through a mountainous
area north of athens with extraordinary
speed catching residents by surprise and
giving them barely any time to escape
george kiryakopoulos has got back to
barry bobby and simply cannot take in
what has happened to his family land or
the much loved home of his father and
mother because if you see this in this
situation she will cry his own home was
badly damaged his dog died in the fire
and george was lucky to escape with his
life
came in ten minutes and grooved us
we're there so you were escaping amid
the flames yes yes
inside the flames with
emergency workers the military along
with locals doing what they can a battle
to prevent further damage hour after
exhausting hour they have made progress
but this scorched land is unforgiving
for miles here vast areas of forest are
still smoldering there's the potential
for small fires to ignite and soon turn
into major blazes the efforts of
hundreds of firefighters still haven't
brought this situation under control
and that is what worries ruler mantis so
much damage yes
she shows us what remains of the
business she runs with her boyfriend
she's frustrated the building was
allowed to burn but understands
firefighters faced impossible pressure
it's very hard it's a lot of money we
have to spend to make this from the
beginning
you can't save anything
as you can see
hundreds are yet to return to varabobby
extraordinary and devastating images
will greet them and so too will the
challenge of trying to recover michelle
clifford sky news greece